18h19 nous sommes en direct c'est un
nouveau moment décisif de la campagne
présidentielle de l'entre-deux tours
marine le pen tient son premier grand
meeting entre le premier et le second
tour la candidate du rassemblement
national et à avignon vous avez vu les
images il ya un instant suivra son
ensemble vous réagissez sur les
différents chat je vous présente ce
qu'ils vont nous faire suivre cet
événement ce soir frédéric micheau
bonsoir frédéric micheau vous êtes
directeur général adjoint d'opinionway
je montre votre votre livre le sacre de
l'opinion une histoire de la
présidentielle et des sondages c'est
vous dire si vous connaissez le sujet on
va en parler ensemble et puis je salue
aussi vincent rosereau vincent raison
bonsoir vous êtes sur place nous ferons
entendre les militants ce soir les
cadres les cadres du parti mais d'abord
expliqué nous le programme
expliquez-nous l'ambiance
[Musique]
eh bien on se retrouve effectivement
avignon au parc des expos d'avignon où
le programme est très simple en fait il
y aura juste une seule prise de parole
celle de marine le pen à 18h45 dont
andorre dans un peu moins d'une demi
heure vous voyez derrière moi les
militants sont présentes ils s'arrêtent
ils sont arrivés depuis 17h il ya encore
quelques quelques sièges vides bien
évidemment à au fond mais les gens
conduite de conduire andré et à l'avant
en tout cas beaucoup de pour une musique
de la musique forte alors la goldman en
ce moment et beaucoup de drapeaux qui
soit agité par les militants en ce
moment
ambiance qu'on peut ressentir de là bas
vous n'hésitez pas vous réagissez sur
les tchats sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube
aussi vous abonner puis vous pouvez vous
pouvez réagir mais je vous pose la
première question frédéric michaud est
ce que les meetings comme ça entre deux
tours ça peut faire la différence ce qui
on le voit dans les sondages
c'est un effet ça c'est un effet d'abord
sur la base militante ça permet de
conserver la mobilisation de générer de
l'enthousiasmé de générer de la
confiance c'est de cette énergie elle
est aussi importante pour la candidate
elle-même qui a besoin de rester motivé
jusqu'à jusqu'à la dernière ligne droite
on sait qu'une campagne électorale
c'est épuisant même version à la 106e ri
la campagne présidentielle c'est le
sprint final mais avant c'est un
marathon exactement et donc c'est bien
cette difficulté là qui est qui qui crée
de la fatigue donc évidemment pour pour
le candidat ou la candidate le meeting
s'est aussi c'est aussi une prise
d'énergie donc c'est quelque chose de
positif après est-ce que ça a un impact
sur le sur le rapport de force en tant
que tels n'ont pas véritablement ça peut
avoir un impact indirect est sans doute
limité à travers les images que les
médias avant restituer notamment dans
les journaux télévisés de 20 heures ce
soir un sans doute ce qui explique
pourquoi le meeting débute à 18h30 c'est
pour pouvoir donner des erreurs dans les
20 heures mais mais sinon c'est plutôt
un effet qui joue d'abord sur la base
sur la base militante et un effet
d'interaction avec entre les candidats
et les personnes qui assistent au
meeting on entendra dans un instant à
avignon mais d'abord je voudrais qu'on
commet de cette image qui est en direct
président de la république candidat
l'autre candidat de ce second tour
emmanuel macron il a passé la journée au
havre avec avec edouard philippe on l'a
vu ce matin très chaleureuse poignée de
main des images en direct alors lui les
dents dans une usine où il parle de
l'écologie mais un vrai clivage là aussi
une bataille des images un marine le pen
en meeting on n'a pas trop trop vu
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron d'huile
occupe le terrain tout au long de la
journée oui alors c'est ce qu'on voit
depuis le début de la semaine c'est une
bataille d'image second tour de ce point
de vue là emmanuel macron a évidemment
tiré
les leçons
médiatico-politique de
l'entre-deux-tours de 2017 vous souvenez
qui s'était un peu laissé surprendre et
avoir le pool notamment par m walpole
notamment par une marine le pen très
active immédiatement sur sur le terrain
donc il n'a pas voulu reproduire cette
erreur et multiplie les déplacements
c'est vraiment le jour et la nuit entre
la campagne d'avant le premier tour le
président avait avait fait une campagne
a minima très peu de déplacements un
seul meeting c'était sans précédent même
françois mitterrand qui avait fait une
campagne beaucoup plus courtes avait
fait 4-4 meeting là il ya un activisme
il ya la volonté d'être présent sur le
sur le terrain et puis d'être en contact
en proximité avec les français on
retente tout de suite à avignon avec
vincent rosereau vincent vous êtes avec
charles sapin qui a signé un très bon
papier ce matin dans le journal
notamment sur marine le pen qui prépare
déjà le débat algérien débat d'accord
mais mais il ya un meeting ce soir avant
tout celui quand même ce que disait
charles sapin plus question de saturer
l'agenda de marine le pen de rendez-vous
de déplacement jusqu'au jour du débat et
ainsi prendre de nouveau le risque
qu'elles s'y présentent exténué c'est
son dernier grand moment avant le débat
c'est ça vincent et charles
je suis sam savage retrace avec moi sur
ma caméra peut déjà journaliste au
figaro spécialiste pas des robots
pourquoi est-ce que ça vous va bien
pour moi
voilà une question aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il faut attendre de marine le pen
sur ce sursaut discours sur ce métier
alors bonjour a tous eu ce qu'il faut
attendre de marine le pen là c'est une
première démonstration de force entre
deux tours c'est son premier meeting
dans son discours elle va allier à la
fois de la continuité par rapport à sa
campagne de premier tour ça va rester
sur des thématiques de pouvoir d'achat
du concret ça c'est pour toucher ses
propres électeurs ça a marché au 1er
tour et a longtemps fait continuer sur
cette voie pour le second c'est à
l'avantagé des thématiques économiques
ont aussi l'avantagé de parler à
l'électorat de gauche
même mélenchonistes puisque les et
thématiques feront dame pas ses
fondamentaux que sont l'immigration la
sécurité par exemple m des thèmes sont
plus répulsives contre et électorat de
gauche ça c'est pour la continuité avec
le premier tour et elle va mettre
l'accent encore plus qu'avant ce premier
tour sur le vote anti macron calais
serait rassemblée derrière elle elle va
représenter en fait son programme comme
le négatif photographique quoi le nez de
vraiment le le parfait contraire
emmanuel macron en posant en fait
l'enjeu de cette élection comme un enjeu
de civilisation
d'ailleurs
continuer avec emmanuel macron
avec l'immigration l'insécurité elle va
faire un bilan des manuels macro sur le
sujet ou
vous n'êtes pas forcément d'accord avec
moi avec mon programme mais votez pour
moi parce que je suis en capacité de
mettre un terme au mandat des manières
mâcon c'est vraiment ces deux choses
qu'elle va allier normalement dans cette
ce premier meeting d'entre deux tours
il est vraiment très important ce
premier grand meeting pour réussir face
à emmanuel bach ou en s'opposant aux
présidentiables qu'elle n'avait pas
forcément réussi à faire il ya cinq ans
oui alors c'est totalement et ses
grandes mobilisations c'est une façon de
se présidentialiser
et c'est vrai que ça tombe à pic parce
que depuis le premier tour on voit dans
les différents sondages qui ont commencé
à tomber par les écarts qui était très
très très proches le soir du premier
tour et sondage pour le second tour on
était sur un 49 51 pour les mâcon
là se creuse c'est vrai que la campagne
est longue marine le pen a vu plusieurs
polémiques
c'est à dire pas cette polémique sur la
façon dont tu as traité certains
journalistes notamment deux quotidiens
il ya eu hier cette militante qui a été
sortie de sa conférence de presse sur la
diplomatie là cette démonstration de
force et se crédibiliser ce présent
présidentialiser et elle espère en fait
tourner un peu la page de ce début de
campagne un peu optant pour pour voilà
accéléré et remonter dans les sondages
réduire cet écart avec emmanuel macron
pour encore une fois parler à ses
troupes et dire ma victoire est possible
contrairement à il ya cinq ans
d'ailleurs les les cadres de marine le
pen le dise il dit voilà en 2017 on est
arrivé au second tour mais au fond de
nous on savait que la victoire était
impossible là ils disent on rails sont
dans leur rôle en mai ils disent là on
sent quelque chose la victoire on la
touche du bout des doigts c'est possible
dernière question avignon faire un
meeting ici avignon sanaa ap ce n'est
pas du hasard c'est très important c'est
une zone géographique très importante
pour marine le pen ah oui tout à fait
mal à le vaucluse
là la région paca elle est arrivée en
tête particulièrement le vaucluse où
elle est arrivée assez largement en tête
devant emmanuel macron lui-même devant
jean-luc mélenchon c'est un optique de
mobilisation comme le disait donc elles
parlent à d'autres électorale elle parle
aussi à son électorat l'enjeu pour
marine le pen c'est
c'est de mobiliser ses troupes de faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas d'abstention
on se souvient du président du précédent
dramatique des régionales où il y avait
une abstention importante notamment chez
les classes populaires qui sont en fait
des électeurs de marine le pen ce qui
fait que tous les élus rassemblement
national avait eu des scores très en
deçà de tout ce qui était pronostiquée
donc même si elle a été qualifiée pour
ce second tour bien un enjeu important
pour marine le pen s'est mobilisée
mobiliser et mobiliser son camp c'est
pour ça qu'elle vient là sont une de ses
terres de force pour dire à ses
électeurs vous des mobiliers ce n'est
pas la victoire est possible merci
beaucoup cherchent à faire d'avoir été
avec nous et merci thibault je vous
laisse repartir en plateau
[Musique]
merci charme oui vous réagissez
évidemment sur sur les différents chat
lefigaro.fr youtube j'ai une question
frédéric micheau d'opinion etc est
toujours avec moi j'ai une question
c'est pas une question c'est une
affirmation plutôt replay harrington sur
youtube qui me dit je ne vois pas ce
qu'elle a de droite marine le pen pour
moi c'est la candidate de gauche s'est
imprimé un set cette attitude très
sociale presque de marine le pen depuis
plusieurs mois alors ce qu'il ya un bris
mais c'est toute sa stratégie de
campagne pour préempter d'une certaine
manière la thématique de pouvoir d'achat
dans les études d'opinion la candidate
qui s'est le mieux saisi de cette
question du pouvoir d'achat qui est une
question cruciale depuis 2 l'automne
avec la hausse des carburants la hausse
des prix de l'énergie d'une manière
générale c'est marine le pen auquel elle
a réussi à être la candidate qui incarne
qui apporte les meilleures réponses aux
à la préoccupation centrale des des
français alors elle reste à droite elle
s'est recentré sous l'effet de
l'apparition d'eric zemmour qui lui
apparaît comme beaucoup plus est apparue
comme beaucoup plus radicales qu'elles
donc par un effet de contraste salle à
recentrer ça adoucit son personnage mais
elles restent quand même perçu comme une
femme de nos adresses mais c'est vrai
que là elle a pas fait par exemple de
déplacement pour l'instant il reste une
semaine n'a pas fait le déplacement par
exemple sur la sécurité c'est oublier ça
au rassemblement national ça n'impacte
plus où c'est un électorat qui est
acquis et donc on va en chercher un
autre voilà c'est exactement ça c'est
une thématique est requise c'est une
thématique qui qui qui est associé
naturellement au rassemblement national
elle en parlera sans doute ce soir pour
pour réactiver tout ça mais vraiment la
priorité c'est cette question c'est
cette question du pouvoir d'achat c'est
cette question
sociale et et pour une raison
stratégique également c'est à dire que
les grandes réserves de voix au delà des
abstentionnistes dont on a parlé elle se
situe chez les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon et donc c'est une partie de
ses électeurs qu'il faut convaincre et
ceux là sont évidemment très sensibles à
ce discours social le trésor de guerre
les voix de jean luc mélenchon au
premier tour j'ai une question qui
revient peut-être à ce qu'on disait au
début marine le pen n'a pas fait pour
l'instant elle ne fera probablement pas
de très grands discours comment peu
comme a pu le faire eric zemmour avec
très visuel vous voyez au trocadéro
comme a pu le faire emmanuel macron à
nanterre et comme il le fera
probablement samedi à marseille ça
marche pas ça les discours strass et
paillettes ça énerve le français ou non
c'est une stratégie de normalisation la
candidate normale presque non ça marche
parce que c'est destiné à créer et une
démonstration de force a montré là la
puissance d'un candidat puissance dans
le nombre de personnes qui assistent aux
meetings puissance dans l'énergie
restituée par la foule rappelons qu'ils
s'agitent les
et les réaction de la foule les
applaudissements évidemment donc ça a un
impact parce que ça renforce et ça
crédibilise un candidat évidemment un
candidat qui fait pas recette dans les
meetings salle démonétise un petit peu
mais en revanche sur la forme ça
correspond à sa stratégie de sobriété
destiné à construire sa présidentialité
voilà je crois que vraiment il ya cette
attention là se concentrer sur le fond
et et sur une posture le plus
présidentiel possible pour montrer
qu'elle a le sens des responsabilités
que c'est une femme d'état s'étaient
inscrits vous vous souvenez sur son
affiche parlez en à parlé évidemment
avec cette sorte de grand écart comme on
a pu le voir hier avec ce discours sur
la diplomatie la politique étrangère ça
c'est une prérogative principal du
présent la présidente de la république
pourquoi pas est à la fois le pouvoir
d'achat très très proche des français on
voit qu'elle veut jouer sur ces sur ces
deux tableaux mais oui et un président
de la république c'est cela c'est
évidemment le domaine réservé la guerre
emmanuel macron on a beaucoup joué
pendant la campagne d'avant le le
premier tour la diplomatie l'europe les
grands équilibres mondiaux évidemment ça
c'est important pour les français un le
rôle de la france sur la scène
internationale et l'image que le
président de la république projette de
la france sur la scène internationale on
se souvient que ça avait beaucoup
pénalisés par exemple président comme
françois hollande et puis aussi d'un
président il doit être capable de rester
à l'écouté des des français c'est
peut-être ce que n'a pas su faire
emmanuel macron dont on n'a pas voulu
faire emmanuel macron dans la campagne
de premier tour là il ya un rattrapage
et marine le pen doit elle aussi pour se
présidentialiser et bien jouer sur ces
deux registres un peu plus de dix
minutes avant que marine le pen prennent
la parole depuis avignon pour son
premier grand meeting on peut voir cette
image du pupitre avec avec qui et tous
ces militants devant vous me parliez des
drapeaux et un instant tous ces
militants qui agitent les drapeaux et or
eux ont rejoint tout de suite vincent
rose rond qui est sur place il est avec
un un militant et je lis un ce qui est
sûr le chat pour pour lancer vincent et
rennes qui est sur youtube et qui nous
dit il faut convaincre le peuple de
gauche vincent c'est ça est-ce que le
monsieur qui est avec vous et est
quelqu'un qui a voté mélenchon non je
crois pas mais il a peut-être conscience
qu'il faut convaincre ce peuple de
gauche c'est aussi
ce
non jacques tu es avec henry qui vient
du bon t'es juste à côté d'avignon et
qui manie qu'il a voté pour le pen
depuis très longtemps
depuis je pas dire toujours mais je
votais déjà jean marie en tout cas cette
cette campagne de la part de marine le
pen elle vous a convaincue elle vous a
plu et c'est ça vous amène aujourd'hui
ici
sa campagne je n'ai même pas regardé
parce qu'ils sont au départ je suis pour
elle aujourd'hui le but c
les cas du but pourquoi être venu ici
aujourd'hui pour montrer que tu étais
présent pour faire bloc tout à fait
être présent et la soutenir est ce que
vous êtes et ce que vous croyez en ses
chances elle était elle est née au coude
à coude actuellement avec emmanuel
patron dans les sondages est ce que vous
y croyez qu est ce qui pourrait
l'empêcher a déjà les sondages y croit
pas
c'est du pipeau
malheureusement
mais bon elle a sa chance et ça fera
peut-être la chance pour la france
très bien merci beaucoup henry
il vous fait une attaque personnelle à
frédéric micheau les sondages ils
croient pas mais vous me disiez en
l'écoutant il a même pas regardé la
campagne ils allaient voter pour marine
le pen ça c'est sa force son socle oui
ça c'est très caractéristique de
l'électorat de marine le pen c'est cette
fidélité au rassemblement national au
front national je dirais même à la
marque le pen il ya quelque chose quand
même de de l'ordre du réflexe politique
qui tient aussi à la sociologie
politique de cet électorat qui est moins
politisés que d'autres qui entrent plus
tardivement en campagne et qui se se
reportent immédiatement vers des choix
qui sont claires et éventuellement des
choix qui l'a déjà fait par le passé
donc il ya une capacité à maintenir son
socle électoral qui est assez élevé chez
marine le pen on voit tous ses militants
sur ces images en direct qui attendent
l'arrivée de marine le pen c'est dans
une dizaine de minutes maintenant
l'électorat de marine le pen ça c'est
intéressant j'ai plusieurs questions à
ceux à ce sujet mc ronger french spirit
qui me dit mais bénéficie du soutien
indéfectible des boumeurs je le mets
entre guillemets personnes plus plus
âgés et des cadres moyens supérieurs des
grandes agglomérations
une vraie différence des lectorats oui
c'est quasiment le jour et la nuit
effectivement emmanuel macron a réussi à
prendre les seniors une clientèle
électorale importante en marketing
politique aux républicains jusqu'à cette
élection c'était les républicains tôt à
droite souvent qu'ils étaient en tête
chez les seniors la désormais c'est
emmanuel macron marine le pen est elle
fait elle avait souvent le vote des
jeunes là elle était concurrencé au
premier tour par jean luc mélenchon et
puis aussi le le deuxième élément c'est
qu'elle a un électorat qui est treize
ouvriers 40 % des ouvriers ont voté pour
pour elle un électorat qui est composé
également de beaucoup d'employés donc
les catégories populaires 1 continue
prioritairement à voter pour marine le
pen c'est aussi un électorat qui est un
petit peu moins diplômés que les autres
cas d un niveau de revenus plus bas vous
voyez toujours ces images en direct et
il a l'air d'avoir de l'ambiance pour ce
premier grand meeting d'entre deux tours
de marine le pen le choix d'avignon il
n'est pas anodin frédéric micheau là je
je je place le contexte avec les scores
du premier tour elle sera à arras la
semaine prochaine à d'ailleurs je le dis
qu il est arrivé où elle était arrivée
en tête elle est arrivée en tête dans le
vaucluse marine le pen c'est une c'est
un département très important historique
pour le front national et puis pour le
rassemblement national est ce qu'elle
est sur une stratégie défensive on a
l'impression qu'elle va dans des lieux
où elle est en confiance où elle a un
électorat où elle a déjà gagné alors que
emmanuel macron dit on l'a vu aller à
denain dans le nord on le voit là
marseille où il n'a fini que 3e ce cas
une différence à ce niveau là est ce que
cette fois cinq ans plus tard clt sur la
défensive emmanuel macron qui est sur
l'offensive alors il faut distinguer les
déplacements de terrain des meetings
d'acorn logique que les hommes
politiques les candidats fasse des
meetings dans les zones dans leurs zones
de force jean luc mélenchon a fini son
meeting à toulouse
c'est pas anormal qu'elle donne qu'elle
fasse un meeting dans dans dans une zone
géographique où elle a fait de bons
scores ce que ça permet justement
d'avoir une mobilisation de personnes
qui qui participent au meeting les
déplacements c'est autre chose emmanuel
macron lui est dans une stratégie où
justement il veut démontrer qu'il est
capable de parler aux français y compris
aux français qui n'ont pas voté pour lui
et qui peuvent être en désaccord avec
lui d'une certaine manière il a besoin
de mettre en scène ce contact avec les
français parce que il ne l'a pas fait
avant le premier tour pour marine le pen
c'est différent elle elle a besoin de
ceux de se présidentialiser
et donc peut-être moins d'être en
contact direct avec avec la population
même si osi elle fait aussi des
déplacements sur le terrain je salue
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr vous posez vos
questions évidemment vous n'hésitez pas
et ensuite cinq minutes normalement la
prise de parole de marine le pen elle
répète souvent sa marine le pen quand le
peuple vote le peuple gagnent c'est un
de ses slogans l axe énormément ces
derniers jours sur ce référendum est une
vraie différence elle veut montrer que
c'est une candidate démocrate
républicaine ça c'est important oui
c'est vraiment crucial pour elle parce
que elle doit mobiliser ses électeurs on
a vu qu aux dernières élections
régionales quand sa base électorale ne
se mobilise pas le rassemblement
national
fait des contre performances et le moins
qu'on puisse dire donc là elle a
vraiment besoin de cela cette affiche
macron le plein du second tour qui
répète la fiche de 2017 elles n'étaient
pas voulues par les français donc il
peut y avoir de la démobilisation dans
l'entre-deux-tours entre les deux tours
de 2017 l'abstention avait progressé de
3 points si c'est la même chose cette
année ce sera évidemment un facteur très
pénalisant pour marine le pen qui a
besoin d'une abstention la plus faible
possible de la participation la plus
élevée possible parce que elle a besoin
que ses électeurs se mobilisent pour
voter pour elle on va retourner à
avignon tout de suite en direct avec
notre envoyé spécial c'est vincent
rosereau vincent on vous laisse la
parole
[Musique]
militant
de marine le pen qui est venu
aujourd'hui au au meeting de marine le
pen à avignon alors pourquoi c'était
important pour vous de venir ici
aujourd'hui
ça fait plus de vingt ans que je milite
je suis un militant également je me suis
même présenter à certaines élections
donc
c'est par esprit
national et je dirais même nationaliste
voilà qui est laïc est également de mise
et bien avec marine le pen vous croyez
en ses chances au deuxième tour
aujourd'hui je suis persuadé qu'elle va
gagner
andy même la presse en général dit
qu'elle est près de gagner mais je suis
de plus en plus persuadés et notamment
grâce à son programme
et au fait que les gens commencent à
connaître son ré programme qui est
notament un programme social 11 points
vous êtes à qui vous arrive et qui vous
a convaincu lui aussi sait ce c'est ce
côté social puis allemande marine le pen
aujourd'hui voilà tout à fait j'ai le
côté social qui m'a convaincu parce que
bien qu'ayant
suivi une carrière de cadre bancaire
j'estime qu'il est encore trop de
français de france est actuellement bien
sûr qu'ils se trouvent en france
2 devrait france et si je peux dire
qu'ils sont encore
les statistiques disent qu'il y a 10
millions de fausses empreintes donc
pourquoi en fait revenir aussi c'est un
de mes combats autant dire de gens de
l'extérieur mais alors qu'on n'en peut
plus et qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire
remonter le niveau de vie de ses 10
millions de proches c'est bien merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été avec
douche voilà thibault pour 7 pour ce
militant qui a été élu par un côté
social de marine le pen qui va arriver
d'ici quelques instants j'avais rebondir
sur ce que disait alain avec frédérick
michaud qui est toujours avec moi et
avec ce que dit jordan sûr sur youtube -
quand j'étais plus jeune je croyais que
marine était raciste puis plus je
grandis plus je les écoute plus je la
comprends et je vois aucun mal dans le
programme et je voudrais d'ailleurs
rebondir sur ce qu'on a pu voir aussi
souvent dans ses meetings on entendait
souvent avant on est chez nous on est
chez nous on sent que quand elle entend
ça dans la foule elle aime plus vraiment
sa marine le pen elle envie de se
dégager de ce côté peut-être nauséabond
qui faisait qui faisait le parti de son
père oui parce que son rôle c'est
d'élargir au maximum
ses soutiens et sa base électorale et
pas deux et pas de se recroqueviller sur
ce qui était initialement le front
national est pas le rassemblement
national donc pour élargir il faut se
respecte à billy's et il faut se
départir de ses discours qui sont très
clivant il faut aussi des montres et des
compétences sur des sujets régaliens sur
l'économie sur la justice sur
l'éducation évidemment sur la sur la
question sociale c'est ce qu'elle s'est
employé à faire il faut monter en
compétences et ça ce sera tout l'enjeu
du débat de la semaine prochaine a
montré qu'elle a énormément progressé
sur la maîtrise des dossiers sur le sur
la connaissance des des grandes
questions bref qu'elle est en mesure
d'entrer à l'elysée est de gouverner
immédiatement pour parler du débat
frédéric justement je voulais venir
avant que marine le pen le pen prennent
la parole ça devrait être dans un
instant début de meeting prévu à 18h45
on a l'impression qu'elle est sur des
rails elle sait faire maintenant ses
meetings elle arrive à apprendre
apprendre la foule est ce que le grand
sujet pour elle c'est ce débat de
mercredi soir est ce que ça peut
impacter les sondages très clairement
est-ce que mercredi soir dans vos
derniers sondages vous pouvez nous dire
ça y est on sait à peu près après ce
sondage qui va remporter l'élection
présidentielle ou pas c'est le grand
c'est le grand enjeu pour elle de cet
entre-deux-tours d'ailleurs on voit bien
qu'elles dégagent du tampon se préparer
elle a beaucoup analysé les chèques pour
pas dire le fiasco de 2010 est elle en a
tiré les conséquences sur la forme et
sur le fond oui elle va devoir réussir
cet exercice on voit le clip de campagne
de marine le pen avant sûrement son
entrée on va on va suivre on va suivre
tout ça sur quoi il peut attaquer
emmanuel macron ce soir marine le pen
sur sur le pouvoir d'achat sur la
sécurité mc kinsey sanon campagne sur
quoi selon vous elle doit axer elle va
axer je pense meeting je pense qu'elle
va faire feu de tout bois et c'est
exactement ce que fait aussi emmanuel
macron donc elle va l'attaquer sans
doute sur tous les éléments de son de
son bilan les questions de sécurité les
questions d'immigration
évidemment la question du du pouvoir
d'achat elle va sans doute mené une
offensive aussi sur le style du
président de la république
à la fois le côté président des riches
donc l'élite l'élite mondialistes pour
reprendre ses thèmes de campagne
jouer jouer à fond le le clivage et même
l'opposition entre ce qu'elle incarne et
et ce qui est censé incarner emmanuel
macron cette conception du pouvoir
arrogante autoritaire et aussi solitaire
voilà sans doute les éléments sur
lesquels elle devrait insister ce soir
chacun son son combat emmanuel macron
lui qui doit faire face à ces questions
la marine le pen souvent à sa position
et elle d'extrême droite on a vu que ces
derniers temps il ya eu beaucoup de deux
questions à ce sujet elle doit toujours
essayer incessamment de montrer qu'elle
n'est pas d'extrême droite alors oui
c'est une question qui lui est
constamment opposée et le chef de l'état
lui ait said évidemment de la renvoyer
dans cette
dent dans ce corner sur sur l'échiquier
électoral on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs dès
avant le premier tour avec la fameuse
expression du tandem eric zemmour marine
le pen
l'extrême droite s'est normalisée le
rassemblement national fait mais fait
des scores qui sont qui sont plus
crédibles auparavant qu'ils sont plus
élevés donc ça ça donne une forme de
légitimité supplémentaire pour autant ce
n'est pas un positionnement politique
comme les autres marine le pen même si
elle a adouci son image elle conserve
quelque chose d'inquiétant dans
dans l'image qu'elle renvoie auprès de
la majorité des français avec michou on
se retrouve juste après parce que marine
le pen arrive on va suivre ces instants
premier grand meeting de second tour
pour pour marine le pen qui est donc à
avignon qui va essayer de mobiliser ses
militants c'est un des grands
rendez-vous on sait qu'elle est ce soir
à avignon elle sera mercredi soir sur le
plateau de tf1 et france 2 pour le grand
débat et puis jeudi à arras 3 moment
très important pour la candidate du
rassemblement national le premier c'est
maintenant on se retrouve juste après
pour analyser tout ça puis me continue à
réagir sur le figaro.fr sur youtube on
vous suit on vous écoute et puis on
répond à tout ce qui s'est dit à tout ce
qui a été commentée pendant allez une
petite heure de discours à tout à
l'heure marine le pen en direct depuis
avignon et on vit ces moments ensemble
sur le figaro live
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
chers amis
nous voilà presque
arrivés au bout du chemin
d'un chemin pour la défense du peuple un
long chemin
souvent pentu
toujours semée d'embûches
traversée de bourrasques chemin que nous
avons parcouru avec chevillée au corps
le sentiment qu'il nous fallait porter
le message d'amour du pays
d'attachement à la nation d'unité du
peuple français
nous avons été entendus et nous voici au
second tour de cette élection
présidentielle
heureux
[Applaudissements]
je veux vous en remercier
compagnon fidèle et courageux
cherpin silencieux et infatigable de
cette conquête des sommets mais aussi
remercier ceux qui nous ont apporté avec
leur vote et donc leur confiance la
force de les atteindre merci donc à vous
merci à vous tous français patriotes de
nous avons accompagné dans ce long
périple merci de nous avoir aidés
soutenus d'avoir été les compagnons de
route fidèle et courageux sans lesquels
je vous le dit avec émotion et gratitude
aucun succès n'est possible
notre courant de pensée et comme la
rivière qui rejoint le fleuve qui
lui-même gagne la mer pour fusionner
naturellement avec elle nous y sommes
prêts nous qui avons le plus beau des
message à délivrer le plus envie de
conquérir les coeurs et les âmes de ceux
qui doutent encore de ceux qui
désespèrent et parfois seraient tentés
par une résignation désormais
injustifiable
ans l'espoir du redressement se lève
c'est pourquoi je dis aux
abstentionnistes
venez voter si le peuple vote ne pas le
gagner
c'est paternellement que nous tendons la
main aux français à tous les français il
m'a fait pour ceux qui veulent avec nous
participé à la conquête de l'avenir une
main engageante pour ceux qui nous
découvrent une main secourable pour ceux
qui en ont besoin mais toujours mes amis
une main amicale et respectueuse c'est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais à tous les
français que nous parlons ces français
de métropole d'outre-mer et du monde ces
français de cette france sur laquelle le
soleil ne se couche jamais
ces français présent dans le monde
entier sur tous les continents et qui
ont amené avec eux une part de notre
beau pays prochaine histoire ou français
de rencontres français de mémoire et
français de coeur nous avons en nous
cette flamme de la patrie qui brûle ce
lien si particulier
qui fait de tous nos compatriotes d'où
qu'ils viennent des frères
héritier d'un peuple bâtisseurs et
découvreur de chercheurs et d'inventeurs
d'un peuple qui a tant de fois fait la
preuve de son génie et de sa bonté nous
n'avons pas honte du passé pas peur du
présent nous avons hâte de l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
à
cette à tous les français que je
m'adresse au delà des appartenances
partisanes alors que c'est du pays dont
il s'agit de la liberté de notre peuple
dont il s'agit que c'est du bien-être et
du futur de nos enfants dont il s'agit
mais à cette élection si particulière
qu'est la présidentielle française qui
voit la désignation ô combien solennel à
la plus éminente des fonctions qu'ils
soient cette offense est presque
individuellement que je m'adresse sans
intermédiaire sans détour et sans fard
qu'il me soit tout de même permis de
remercier les personnes ou les groupes
de personnes qui ont d'ores et déjà fait
l'honneur de leur encouragement leur
soutien ou de leur engagement à mes
côtés ils rejoignent la cohorte de ceux
qui venus de tous les horizons se sont
déjà levé pour le sursaut du pays est
aujourd'hui marche pour reprendre
l'expression du général de gaulle à
propos des combattants de la france
libre vers le soleil de la grandeur à
tous
patriotes de droite
patriote de grand chose d'ailleurs
te dis dans cette élection qui nous
voient rassemblés pour le redressement
du pays notre seul parti c'est la france
notre seul moteur ce sont les français
notre seul but c'est la nation
qu'il me soit tout de même autorisé de
dire avec reconnaissance que le rapide
témoigne de l'ampleur de la richesse de
la diversité du rassemblement populaire
qui est en train de se créer cela est
sain lorsque l'intérêt national est en
jeu lorsqu il nous faut rompre avec
l'iniquité d'un pouvoir lorsque les
hommes de bonne volonté prennent le
parti de surmonter leurs divergences
ponctuelles lorsque l'essentiel est en
jeu
que cela puisse inspirer d'autres
ralliements d'autres soutiens d'autres
marques positif que j'accueillerai avec
le même bonheur la même humilité comme
un geste qui encourage mais je vous le
dis aussi comme un signe une relation
qui oublient qui m'oblige
cela chacun peut le comprendre au terme
d'un quinquennat qui aura divisé
méprisé blessés et errer
une errance une errance malheureuse
coûteuse ruineuse une errance oh bien
sûr maquiller de jouvence habillé de
sourire enjôleur ripoliné d'une
prétendue compétence mais dont il nous
faut aujourd'hui réparer les
conséquences et parfois les tragiques
conséquences
en qualifiant au second tour de cette
élection emmanuel macron et moi même le
peuple avec sa grande intelligence
collective a voulu que se déroule le
débat politique est essentielle un débat
qui serbie aujourd'hui dans toutes les
démocraties d'europe entre deux visions
du monde
la vision mondialiste d' emmanuel macron
elle prône la dérégulation et asservi
l'homme aux logiques économiques et
comptables
aux lois du marché et à l'argent roi la
vision nationale que je porte qui défend
la nation comme espace protecteur qui
postule que l'économie est au service de
personnes et de la nation et non le
contraire que l'homme n'est pas
seulement un agent économique mais un
être d'affection de filiation et de
transmission il ya derrière ce soit mes
amis une conception de l'homme pour les
mondialistes l'homme se réduit à n'être
qu'un consommateur ou un producteur un
être interchangeables qui a vocation à
s'installer où il veut a erré dans un
monde sans frontières à vivre ou
survivre d'ailleurs de petits boulots
quand il ne fait pas partie de la caste
pour nous il est un être attaché aux
siens à son pays à sa culture à sa
langue un être unique qui trouve dans
les communautés que sur la famille et la
nation que sont les syndicats ou les
associations de tous ordres qui au sens
littéral du terme anime notre pays
les seules infections durable parce
qu'elles sont fraternels ces communautés
sont les seuls vrais et les teams
protection pour le peuple français c'est
cela le vrai débat
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce n'est pas les amis qu'on voulu
les français mais elle macron lui avec
une certaine fébrilité
semble vouloir y échapper en s'abîmant
dans des propos injurieux ou des
anathèmes télécommandé
je le dis avec gravité
un candidat à la présidentielle au
second tour ne devrait pas se comporter
ainsi
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'ailleurs étonnant parce que ce
candidat président qui refusa d'être
candidat au premier tour pour n'être que
président et qui au second tour pense
pouvoir naître que candidat en oubliant
qu'il est aussi président
[Musique]
le 24 avril si les français ont à faire
barrage set au retour d'emmanuel
matheron
[Applaudissements]
oui
verbiage faire barrage à l'effondrement
du pouvoir d'achat des français faire
barrage au matraquage fiscal faire
barrage à la retraite à 64 ou 65 ans et
plus
[Applaudissements]
général et senior travailler jusqu'à
l'épuisement physique pour des pensions
de misère faire barrage au laxisme
judiciaire qui livre les personnes à une
délinquance devenue endémique faire
barrage à une immigration qui met en
péril les équilibres de nos systèmes
sociaux et justifie une dépense
d'énergie dont la société aurait besoin
dans d'autres projets faire barrage un
nouveau quinquennat de désolation
sociale et de déconstruction nationale
car barrage aussi les amis à cette caste
qui nous gouvernent avec arrogance ce
pouvoir de quelques-uns au bénéfice de
quelques-uns ce pouvoir de lens reçoit
où règnent cooptation népotisme qui
illustre parfaitement les affaires ms et
mckinsey et bien sûr alstom
rappelez vous ces mots terribles qui ont
été
égrénés tout au cours du quinquennat
ces mots de mépris et d'inutiles
tensions
ceux qui ne sont rien lennon lennan
essentiels ceux qui n'auraient pas le
courage de traverser la rue pour trouver
un emploi les ouvrières illettrés ou
bien encore ceux qui fument des clopes
et roulent au diesel
mais ses mots ces mots sont d'une
violence symbolique terrible ce sont les
mots d'un pouvoir sans empathie qui
suppose une relation avec le peuple
envisagé comme un rapport de force comme
la mise en concurrence et même en
opposition de tous contre tous comme
l'écrasement des faibles ce rendez vous
du 24 avril vous l'avez compris mesdames
et messieurs met face à face le bloc
populaire contre le bloc élitaire le
bloc dessus attachés à la sécurité
sociale contre le bloc de ceux attachés
au pouvoir de l'argent le bloc dessus
attaché au service public contre le bloc
de ceux qui vendent des fleurons de
notre industrie le bloc de ceux qui
considèrent le peuple comme le seul
souverain contre le bloc qui concède le
pouvoir aux seuls techniciens
bref le peuple contre l'oligarchie
mais cette oligarchie ne représente ni
la compétence pardon est là effondré
l'école et l'hôpital public ni le
sérieux emmanuel macron les 600
milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire à notre pays
ni la morale les affaires politico
judiciaires pour régulièrement la une
des journaux ce peuple en revanche c'est
vous personne modeste personne des
classes moyennes ou même des classes
aisées qui subissait ce pouvoir qui le
jugeait pour ce qu'il est ce pouvoir
dont vous ne voulez plus donc en réalité
plus grand monde ne veut
emmanuel macron n'était pas l'homme
d'une nouvelle ère mais le dernier
avatar d'un système qui a vécu
je crois enfin que le moment est venu de
fermer une parenthèse d'un système à
bout de souffle
hsm
centré autour d'un homme un homme seul
une caste aux abois qui n'a plus rien à
produire visiblement des invectives
un régime qui n'a plus rien à apporter
que des scandales et des polémiques et
dont le seul projet est de se perpétuer
bref un système qui n'a plus rien à dire
que encore
nous nous proposons au pays un projet
réellement alternatifs parce que
fondamentalement nous portons une
inaltérable passion de l'avenir
cette passion de l'avenir que nous
voulons transmettre comme un remède au
désespoir qui est train ou à la
dépression qui retient nous voulons
faire triompher le beau projet pour la
france qui est le nôtre pas pour nous
pas pour je ne sais quel amour propre
qui serait mal placé et qui ne nous
ressemble pas pas non plus par je ne
sais quelles ambitions personnelles qui
ne nous habite pas mais pour la seule
ambition qui motive celle pour notre
pays pour l'amour profond que nous
portons aux peuples et aux gens par
attachement à la justice à la vérité à
la liberté
[Applaudissements]
je crois je crois que notre projet
ressemble à la france
cette france qu'on aime
cette france qui inventa la nation qui
défendit tout au long de son histoire le
droit des peuples fonda son pacte social
sur la nature elle solidarité nationale
cette france qui ne demande qu'à
éclairer à nouveau le monde de sa
lumière je crois qu'il correspond à la
france d'aujourd'hui en proie aux doutes
et aux multiples fracturation du temps
et des hommes et qui a besoin de se
ressourcer dans ses principes fondateurs
la sécurité républicaine face à la loi
des mafias et des caïds un la laïcité
qui doit être réaffirmé devant la
poussée d'un obscurantisme qui opprime
les femmes défi nos valeurs et verse
dans le terrorisme
l'égalité celle de la justice sociale
celle de la méritocratie
celle qui donne à chacun la chance
d'évoluer dans la société la liberté
celle de s'exprimer de penser de créer
et d'entreprendre de prescrire ou même
de rêver liberté qui ont été tant
bafoués durant ce quinquennat
il est maintenant temps de remettre la
france en ordre nous le ferons un cinq
ans
nous la ferons parce qu'en vérité mes
amis hier n'a jamais vraiment été tenté
aucune solution réellement l alternative
n'a été essayé les pouvoirs se sont
succédé avec le même formatage
idéologique le mondialisme les mêmes a
priori politique
la déréglementation généralisée les
mêmes méthodes oligarchique de
contournement de la volonté du peuple
les mêmes mensonges d'état il ne faut
pas s'étonner que les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets et que le
sablier du temps ensevelie chaque jour
davantage notre cher pays son énergie
ses espoirs c'est l'école française qui
faisait hier notre fierté qui dégringole
aujourd'hui dans les classements
internationaux
ce sont nos fleurons industriels qui ont
été dépecés
entraînant une baisse dramatique du
poids de l'industrie dans notre pib ce
sont nos hôpitaux tellement malmené que
les soignants abandonnent leur si beau
métier et pardon mais c'est la liberté
de la presse qui recule nous plaçant
aujourd'hui en 34e position sur le plan
mondial derrière l'uruguay et le ghana
malheureusement le déclassement n'est
pas un sentiment mais une réalité
tangible pour les français nous ce que
nous proposons pour son redressement
nous le ferons nous le réussirons parce
que j'y suis prête et que notre projet
est solide et réaliste je souhaite me
présenter aux français avec l'idée que
je défends que seul ce qui est élevé
rassemble c'est là la seule idée
la seule haute idée qu ici à la fonction
présidentielle
s'est levé s'élever au dessus des partis
des factions des intérêts particuliers
des petites mesquineries pour ne servir
que l'intérêt général le bien commun le
destin national
notre projet vous le savez nous l'avons
voulu équilibrer parce que la raison le
commande et la fonction présidentielle
l'exigent les constats ils sont
courageux vous pouvez en juger sans
concession nous prenons le peuple
français pour un peuple adultes les
mises en perspectives sont toujours
exprimées de manière sobre et ayez
chiffrer la vérité mes amis n'a pas
besoin d'excès il n'est pas de remède
bien sûr sans appréhender les symptômes
il n'est pas de guérison sans poser un
diagnostic lucide
des solutions elles nous sont inspirés
par une seule logique on ne résout les
problèmes d'un pays que dans l'unité et
la fraternité dans la concorde et
l'écoutent dans la persuasion et non
dans l'affirmation
bien sûr que nous avons voulu ce projet
complet parce que institutionnellement
l'ampleur des responsabilités d'un
président de la république française
l'amène embrassait tous les sujets les
plus internationaux comme les plus
individuelle
intervenir à l'onu et le lendemain
trouver une solution pour aider une mère
célibataire ou une femme victime de
violences conjugales
mais surtout parce que politiquement
les français ont un droit inaliénable à
une protection complète la protection
physique comme la protection sociale
c'est la protection du régalien la
justice la police l'armée la sécurité la
tranquillité le contrôle de
l'immigration de la préservation de nos
identités nationales ou locales
c'est aussi les amis la protection du
quotidien votre pouvoir d'achat
l'excellence de l'école de vos enfants
la qualité de vos logements et de votre
cadre de vie mais aussi parce que votre
liberté n'a pas de prix et notamment
votre liberté de circulation le prix de
votre plein ou de votre train la
protection
c'est aussi bien sur la santé et je vous
l'annonçais je réintégrerai les 15000
soignants expulsés comme damon forme
[Applaudissements]
mais je me limiterai pas mes chers amis
à les réintégrer je leur verseraient les
salaires dont ils ont été injustement
privés en les jetant dans l'angoissé et
le désespoir
et oui je l assume
se préoccuper de la vie concrète de nos
compatriotes c'est aussi cela être
président de la république et j'ose même
penser que le fait d'être une femme est
sur ce point un atout
ce projet
ce projet il veut renouer avec une
ambition celle de rendre à la france sa
place dans le monde celle d'une france
respecté pour sa bienveillance
admiré par son rayonnement suivi pour
son indépendance
vous le savez je veux que la france ne
soit le vassal de personnes cela
implique que la france elle même ne
traite personnes en vassal et c'est
parce que nous sommes profondément
attachés à la souveraineté de notre pays
que nous défendons celles de tous les
pays du monde celle de l'irak en 2003
celles de l'ukraine en 2022
la france elle doit redevenir une
puissance de paix une ambassadrice du
respect des peuples le défenseur des
pays sans voix l'artisan d'un dialogue
entre les nations c'est pourquoi si je
suis élu je proposerai que l'inde
rejoigne et membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité ainsi qu'un pays africain
qui pourrait être celui qui préside
l'union africaine cette réforme des
instances internationales m'apparaît
correspondre au monde d'aujourd'hui
ce monde multipolaire et participera
j'en suis convaincu à la stabilité du
monde pour tout vous dire j'ai
influerait pour que ce siège africain
soit attribuée au sénégal pays sage et
respecté de la grande afrique
non nous ne sommes pas refermés sur
nous-mêmes
nous ne sommes pas refermés sur nous
mêmes nous regardons le monde nous
oeuvrerons à la mise en place d'une
instance de coopération des pays
méditerranéens projet heureux d'un
quinquennat précédent qui
malheureusement n'a pas abouti nous
appuierons pour cela notamment sur des
pays amis comme le maroc et israël ma
première visite sera consacrée à
l'europe au titre de la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne je réunirai les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens pour
évoquer les évolutions nécessaires pour
remettre les instances européennes au
service des peuples est transformée peu
un peu l'union européenne en une
alliance européenne des nations
soyons pragmatiques
l'europe de la commission européenne a
eu sa chance
elle a échoué
pire son échec on l'a vu avec le brésil
a entaché et entamer l'idée européenne
nous allons recoudre cette belle idée
européenne à laquelle nous croyons qui a
été déchiré par la démarche autoritaire
de l'union européenne
fondamentalement vous savez nous faisons
que renouer avec les valeurs de l'europe
plurimillénaire que sont la liberté la
promotion de la diversité des cultures
nationales la préservation des
spécificités locales ou d'un point de
vue opérationnel le strict respect du
principe de subsidiarité
un google européen oui des normes
inutile et sclérosante non par exemple
voilà l'union européenne que nous
contesterons une fois élu
celle qui multiplie les normes qui
écarte des marchés les indépendants les
tpe et pme au profit des seuls grands
groupes celle qui refuse de mettre le
nucléaire dans les énergies de
transition ça qui va entraver les
investissements dans l'industrie de
défense pourtant fondamental pour notre
souveraineté et pour notre économie
celles qui encouragent le travail des
tâches et créant de fait une priorité
étrangères à l'emploi celle qui promeut
les traités de libre échange qui
fragilise nos agriculteurs et font peser
un risque sur la qualité de notre
alimentation
revanche avec les pays qui le souhaitent
nous engagerons notamment par le biais
d'agents sale image d'ariane ou d'airbus
des coopérations européennes sur la mer
sur l'intelligence artificielle sur la
production des données sur les
développements de la filière hydrogène
et puis et puis il ya le social je le
dis parce que
emmanuel macron vient d'en ouvrir la
sinistre perspective la construction de
l'europe ne doit pas être le prétexte ou
le levier pour effondré nos systèmes
sociaux
lorsque emmanuel macron propose un smic
européen
vous devez savoir ce que cela signifie
un nivellement par le bas des niveaux de
vie de salaire de la protection sociale
dont jouissent les pays les plus avancés
dont évidemment la france fait partie
mais ce type de mesures est exactement
dans le prolongement de sa proposition
sur le rsa avec un travail obligatoire à
6 euros de l'heure défendue aujourd'hui
par emmanuel macron sauf peut-être
quelques affairistes personne ne veut de
cela en france personne
moi au contraire je rendrai leur argent
aux français je remettrai à l'honneur la
valeur travail et pour cela nous nous
attacherons à ce que le travail paie
ça a l'air de les déranger beaucoup mais
oui je l'assument mes premières mesures
concerneront le pouvoir d'achat avec la
baisse de la tva sur l'énergie naissance
9 yole l'électricité
et le passage à zéro tva sur un panier
de 100 produits de première nécessité
cette chance
[Applaudissements]
à
je m'attaquerai à vos dépenses
contraintes à commencer par les impôts
les redevances et les taxes qui vous
écrasent les entreprises qui feront
l'effort d'augmenter l'ensemble des
salaires de 10% seront récompensés par
le gel de l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales a fait rentrer pendant cinq
ans cette mesure qui ne crée pas contre
un mot ce que j'ai pu entendre de
dépenses nouvelles pour les finances
publiques n'entamera pas la queue vous
pettiti vite et des entreprises et
permettra aux salariés de voir augmenter
le chiffre en bas à droite dans l'homme
de leur bulletin de salaire
je vais également vous le savez je
voulais dit toute la campagne
je veut miser sur la jeunesse
et oui je veux permettre à nos enfants
de se lancer dans la vie de s'installer
c'est pour cela que je souhaite que les
alternants et apprentis voient leurs
salaires revalorisés de 230 à 330 euros
selon la rage
mais l'apprentissage
et l'alternance doivent redevenir la
voie royale vers le marché du travail et
nous donnerons une prime aux étudiants
qui travaillent pourquoi et bien
justement parce qu'ils travaillent
[Applaudissements]
à
je crois profondément mes amis comme
vous à la valeur travail
il me semble juste de soutenir ceux qui
jeunes pour le soin de mettre leur
talent au service de la société
l'état dispensera tous les jeunes
d'impôt sur le revenu jusqu'à 30 ans
et j'ai créé leur entreprise
ils seront exonérés d'impôt sur les
sociétés durant cinq ans je veux enfin
que l'état veille à des pensions jamais
inférieur à 1000 euros
je veux connaître veille un habitat
digne je veux aussi que l'état veille à
soutenir les aidants quand tant de
familles doivent se débrouiller seul et
supporter des pertes de revenus parfois
importantes je pense notamment aux
familles de personnes touchées par la
maladie d'alzheimer
nous appuierons mais à nous
nous appuierons le retour d'une
croissance soutenue de la prospérité de
la création d'emplois notamment des
jeunes grâce à un changement de modèle
économique plus patriote plus écologique
plus sûres mais c'est le localisme
et louis celles localisées à la solution
c'est à dire la production et la
consommation sur place ce qui suppose la
mise en oeuvre de circuits courts une
politique de label les étiquetages
d'origine une lutte contre les fraudes à
l'importation la valorisation du savoir
faire français
la culture de l'excellence française
l'écologie ça n'est pas empêché les plus
pauvres de nos compatriotes d'entrer
dans les villes à cause des zones à
faibles émissions parce que leur voiture
serait trop viennent
l'écologie c'est mettre fin au
mondialisme dont en réalité seuls les
ultra riches bénéficient
préserver notre modèle social et en même
temps préserver notre planète et bien
voilà deux facettes de mon modèle
économique dès mon élection nous
sortirons les entreprises du piège des
prêts garantis par l'état les fameux pge
mis en place durant le coc vide mais il
faut aider les entreprises par un
rééchelonnement adapté des
remboursements sans inscription à la
banque de france il serait quand même
particulièrement injuste que les
entreprises périssent d'un dispositif
qui était censée les sauver
nous allons enfin
ouvrir le grand chantier du
ressourcement démocratique de notre
république
enfin enfin nous allons donner corps aux
légitimes revendications des mouvements
de rue injustement réprimer comme les
gilet jaune en instaurant le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
et l'inspiration démocratiques tels
respiration démocratique 500 mille
citoyens pourront s'emparer d'un sujet
et ainsi avoir l'initiative d'une
consultation populaire
pour permettre la juste représentation
des opinions de toutes les opinions même
minoritaires nous instaurons une
proportionnelle permettant à tous les
courants d'être représenté dans nos
assemblées
parce qu'il faut donner l'exemple
et que nous voulons sans attendre
éveillé cette démocratie référendaire
nous engagerons le référendum sur
l'immigration pour soumettre ce sujet au
pays
a grand débat mes amis un grand débat
qui n'a jamais eu lieu il faut en faire
arbitrer les solutions clés en main
directement par les électeurs
enfin parce que la liberté du citoyen
est au coeur de mon projet je rendrai à
tous les français des villes des
banlieues ou des campagnes leur sécurité
et même leur tranquillité
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux plus
que des maires tremblent pour leurs
enfants soient qu'ils versent dans la
délinquance soit qu'ils en sont les
victimes je combattrai les trafics de
drogue terreau de la délinquance je
resterai la loi républicaine partout où
des féodalités mafieuse les clips ou
chercher à remplacer je redonnerai aux
femmes la liberté
le droit absolu de ne pas être harcelé
dans l'espace public ou d'être obligé à
des stratégies d'évitement
[Musique]
les femmes ne doivent plus être des
proies elles doivent être libres et
respecté
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
oh
[Applaudissements]
à
enfin mes amis parce que l'élection
présidentielle permet de dessiner le
pays que nous voulons organiser
notre projet met en place une véritable
révolution territoriales pour rétablir
la justice et notamment la justice en
faveur de notre ruralité six abandonnées
et pourtant tellement nécessaire à
l'équilibré du pays notre grand projet
d'aménagement du territoire vous le
savez porte le nom de d métropolisation
hausse apparaît un peu barbare comme ça
comme non mais il s'agit en réalité pour
l'état stratège de reprendre en main
l'aménagement du territoire pour mettre
fin à la concentration d'activités
uniquement dans les métropoles
régionales ou nationales
l'essor de côté des millions de français
il y a une politique de la ville avec
moi il y aura une grande politique des
campagnes
puis nous mettrons en place des
incitations fiscales à l'emménagement
aux zones rurales une vigoureuse
politique
d'infrastructures des routes de
transport de couverture numérique de
rénovation des zones industrielles et
d'activités
d'ouverture d'entrée et de sortie
d'autoroute supplémentaires nous y
encourageront l'installation de pôles
d'excellence nous rééquilibreront les
subventions nous restituerons au maire
leur pouvoir afin de rétablir dans notre
pays la démocratie de proximité mais
aussi la démocratie de contrôle
nous soutiendrons aussi d'ailleurs les
conseillers et les exécutifs municipaux
notamment dans les petites communes pour
reconnaître leur engagement civique en
faveur du bien commun
vous pourrez en juger
mesdames et messieurs la vision que nous
portons ne relève pas d'un catalogue de
mesures mais d'un projet à court moyen
et long terme nous agirons sur cinq ans
mais construire ont pour les décennies
qui suivent ce projet tient sur ses deux
pieds je voulais dit le régalien et le
quotidien une vision pour la france une
vision pour les français pour tous les
français
jeudi pour tous les français parce que
nous sortons d'une période l'action
publique ne fut pas au bénéfice de tous
mais au bénéfice de quelques-uns
alors vous l'avez vu depuis quelques
jours la perspective d'une victoire de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron semblent
leur faire perdre leur sang froid
et même
et même tout bon sens
l'ait fait news les procès d'intention
les provocations les outrances
les diffamations foisonnent un ministre
important pourtant
a même cru pouvoir affirmer je suit
avec marine le pen les pauvres vont
peut-être mourir
[Musique]
rien de moins
certains vont même jusqu'à prétendre
prétendre que je pourrai retirer des
droits aux français alors
je vous le dis de manière solennelle je
ne retirerai aucun droit à aucun
français
[Applaudissements]
avouez-le 1
on nage depuis trois jours dans le grand
n'importe quoi
dans une paranoïa totalement puéril
alors pardon mais comme beaucoup de
français comme peut-être et je le crois
une majorité moi je crois c'est un
quinquennat de plus d' emmanuel macron
qui est un risque pour le pays
[Applaudissements]
non non non non non non non non non non
il reste quelques jours à attendre quand
même
a tous je dis
à tous je dis
soyez libres
ne vous laissez pas abuser par les
gesticulations d'un système qui ne sait
rien faire d'autre que se défendre se
défendre pour conserver ses prébendes se
défendre pour vous des saisir d'un
pouvoir qui s'empresseront d'ailleurs
très vite de concéder à bruxelles ou à
des cabinets de conseil américain
m
ces agitations ont quand même un grand
mérite celui de révéler les connivences
et les accointances qu'habituellement on
vous cache
c'est pourquoi ne vous laissez pas
dicter votre vote
puisse
restons polis puisque nous sommes au
printemps c'est le printemps
cette saison de l'espérance et de la vie
je vous propose de faire de ce 24 avril
un printemps français
après tant pour chacun d'entre vous
à prat en français pour une france plus
fraternelle
plus sûre d'elle-même une france
ressourcer dans ses valeurs les valeurs
qui ont fait d'elle une grande nation
il reste exactement dix jours
dix jours pour convaincre 10 jours pour
vaincre
toutes les voies mon compte et ne
ménagez denis votre temps ni votre
énergie
la ligne d'arrivée est en vue et les
derniers mètres vont être les plus
difficiles
mais
[Applaudissements]
mais mes amis je sais combien la volonté
de notre peuple et puissance et combien
sa détermination à reprendre le contrôle
est forte
c'est pourquoi mes amis ne doutons pas
dans la victoire elle n'a jamais été si
proche ce sera la victoire de la france
une victoire pour tous les français vive
la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez les jeunes
à l'aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà dix jours pour convaincre 10 jours
pour vaincre vous venez de suivre en
direct avec nous sur le figaro live ce
premier grand meeting de marine lepen
dans cet entre-deux-tours depuis avignon
meeting cours
46 minutes très précisément futur avec
frédéric micheau d'opinionway et merci
d'être avec moi on va débattre on va
essayer d'analyser ce qui s'est passé
vous réagissez sur le chat de youtube
sur le chat du figaro.fr on sera à
nouveau avignon dans un instant avec
avec vincent rozon
qu'est ce que vous retenez précisément
ce ya un grand point frédéric à retenir
de ces 46 minutes de discours demain
globe mais j'en retiens deux ados si
vous me le permettez à l'ordre de 1
point sur la forme cette volonté très
nette de retourner tous les arguments
qui manuel macron lui oppose par exemple
emmanuel macron ne cesse de dire qu'il
faut faire barrage
au rassemblement national elle a eu
toute une toute une partie de son
discours consacré à la nécessité de
faire barrage à emmanuel macron qui a
effondré le pouvoir d'achat la retraite
à 64 65 ans le laxisme judiciaire
l'immigration etc ça a été une partie
importante de son discours et puis
emmanuel macron dit aussi que ce serait
un saut dans l'inconnu qui a un risque
pour le pays si jamais elle était élue
président de la république extrême et
elle a renvoyé cet argument disons que
le vrai risque ce serait un nouveau
quinquennat d'emmanuel matheron d'oakley
ya quelque chose d'assez intelligent de
2,2 renvoyé l'argument emmanuel matériel
à utiliser le terme faire barrage on dit
souvent faire barbara brassens nationale
c'est ce qu'elle a dit faire barrage à
emmanuel macron pour les retraites pour
l' effondrement social pour le laxisme
pour les élites et le deuxième point je
vous laisse alors là c'est le deuxième
point g j'ai trouvé que le va et vient
entre les thèmes très concrets de la vie
quotidienne et puis de l'autre côté les
grandes thématiques de la politique du
chef de l'état le domaine réservé dont
on parlait tout à l'heure la politique
internationale la politique européenne
les questions de 2 de sécurité au niveau
au niveau étatique les instances
internationales
elle a proposé quand même 2 6 2 nouveaux
sièges au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
l'un pour le sénégal l'autre pour pour
l'inde s'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on
peut attendre historiquement du
rassemblement national non et puis voilà
ce va-et-vient constant elle a dit par
exemple le régalien et le quotidien la
france et les français j'ai trouvé que
ça c'était vraiment la ligne directrice
de son discours et c'est aussi ce qui
est attendu d'un chef de l'état d'être
au contact des citoyens de la population
à l' écoute des français mais aussi de
gérer les grands enjeux de la france sur
la scène internationale je reprends une
de ses phrases pour pour montrer cette
alternance entre l'international et et
la politique du quotidien pouvoir parler
à l'onu et le lendemain trouver une
solution à une femme battue c'est ça un
président ou une présidente de la
république est capable de parler aux
deux et peut-être que si elle fait ça
c'est qu'elle considère que malgré le
match nul pas été capable de le faire
oui c'est sans doute une façon de
rappeler qu emmanuel macron au moins
dans la dernière séquence est évidemment
dans la campagne d'avant le 1er tour a
été par volonté et par contrainte
absorbée par les questions
internationales et et vouloir ancrer
l'idée qu'il a délaissé les français
qu'il est qu'il est éloigné du terrain
qu'il ne les comprends plus y compris
aussi dans son style un style
d'arrogance un style de mépris un style
anti démocratique d'ailleurs ya toute
une partie intéressante de la fin de son
discours sur ce qu'elle appelle le
ressourcement
démocratique avec la proposition d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
clin d'oeil assez appuyé au gilet jaune
d'ailleurs à la cité les les gilet jaune
puis toute une série d'autres mesures
donc vraiment là la volonté de de faire
une avancée démocratique ça aussi c'est
une façon de prendre le contre-pied de
ce que lui reprochent emmanuel macron
vous réagissez évidemment sur sur les
différentes salles prend vocation vous
n'hésitez pas frédéric micheau vous
répond autre point quand même qu'on a
entendu à la elle a commencé par ça et
elle a fini par ça avec cette phrase
patriotes de droite de gauche d'ailleurs
notre seul parti c'est la france est
toujours cette phrase un qu'elle répète
c'est son second secondes je me disais
tout à l'heure l'un des rares qu'on
retient si le peuple vote le peuple
gagnent elles parlent aux
abstentionnistes l'ain oui absolument
elle parle aux abstentionnistes avant
tout il ya quasiment il ya plus de douze
millions de personnes qui se sont
abstenus au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il faut faire en sorte
qu'ils en aient le moins études et à
surtour les abstentionnistes du futur
ceux qui ont voté peut-être jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour absolument
absolument c'est aussi un set c'est
vraiment un des enjeux de ce second tour
d'ailleurs pour les deux candidats un
pur pour elle comme pour emmanuel macron
parvenir à capter les électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon on voit bien aussi la
cette volonté comme vous le disiez à
l'instant de dépasser son strict
périmètre politique deux premiers tours
elle a la volonté de s'élever au dessus
des partis je reprends ses mots de
rechercher l'intérêt général de
rechercher le bien commun elle a aussi
beaucoup insisté sur la solidité de son
projet sur un projet réaliste donc là
c'est toujours cette recherche de
présidentialité de crédibilité kate kate
importante pour elle et puis cette idée
d'avoir une présidence apaisé de créer
de la concorde de créer de l' écoute ça
aussi c'est vraiment à l'opposé de ce
que reproche emmanuel macron en tout cas
du tableau
très négatif qu'il dresse de deux ans
cas dans le cas hypothétique d'un accès
de marine le pen à à l'elysée d'une
france à feu et à son côté l'attitude
reste à sourire vous voyez où elle a
tout de suite me dis aux français on va
être ensemble presque jose reprendre le
slogan de fabien roussel la france des
jours heureux quand on est on est
presque là demain avec toujours cette
attitude bienveillante les bras ouverts
ces c'est une différence pas forcément
dans l'offensive voyez pencher sur la
table a attaqué manuel mâcon ça c'est un
vrai changement au delà du discours ira
surmonte d'attitude de mind alors il ya
eu quand même des parties très offensive
hier évidemment elle va révéler oculaire
et le bloc à lithaire on va y venir dans
un instant elle a quand même attaqué et
l'a quand même porté porter l'offensive
mais mais il y avait cette volonté
d'ailleurs quai paquet pas nouvelle de
bonnes de dépasser son courant de
rassembler 2 et de rassurer les
électeurs marine le pen qui prend un
bain de foule avec ses militants à
avignon avec ses images de renvoyer
spécial vincent heureusement qu'on va
essayer de rejoindre dans un instant il
nous dira ce qu'il a vu ce qu'il a
entendu pendant pendant ce meeting alors
justement je voulais y venir avec ce que
nous dit philippe piat bourdin sur
youtube virons macron bon on a compris
de quel bord politique il était le
président mckinsey ça c'est important ce
fameux bloc populaire bloc élitaire elle
l'a beaucoup elle a beaucoup insisté là
dessus avec cette idée de mépris on vous
méprise au profit de quelques-uns
cette idée de mépris elle a rappelé
aussi toutes les petites phrases
malheureuses
moins qu'on puisse dire du chef de
l'état qui ont été prononcées pendant
son quinquennat mêmes et même avant
quand il était encore ministre de de
l'économie pour bien insister sur sur ce
mépris c'est le terme quel employé sur
la violence symbolique mais aussi c'est
ton c'est son expression de ses de ses
mots et puis pour dresser évidemment un
contraste entre un chef de l'état au
teint qui ne comprend pas qui ne
comprendraient pas les réalités du
peuple et puis elle même qui est dans
une qui veut se placer dans une posture
d'écouté et de proximité avec les
citoyens on va me dire dans l'oreillette
évidemment si on peut rejoindre vincent
rose rond sur place et puis je vous lis
quand même ce que nous dira inquiète mme
farrow dream sur sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit jamais vu un président aussi
liberticide que macron elle a insisté là
dessus marine le pen la liberté la
liberté comme si c'était la principale
représentante de la liberté sa tranche
aussi avec avec ces accusations ça
permet peut-être de déconstruire ces
accusations d'extrême droite oui
absolument alors c'est le retour aux
fondamentaux de la république elle a
cité la sécurité la cité
l'égalité la laïcité
évidemment non qu'il ya cette volonté là
aussi de s'approprier les grands les
grands principes de la république et et
donc d'une certaine manière de se placer
en rupture avec les thèmes classiques de
de l'extrême droite c'est cette volonté
du ressourcement démocratique elle a
bien insisté sur le fait que pas un
droit ne serait enlevé aux français au
cours d'un éventuel quinquennat donc
toujours cette volonté de gommer tous
les éléments qui pourraient susciter de
l'inquiétude de rassurer pour attirer un
maximum de suffrages en parlant de la
liberté a entendu une clameur à un
moment le supérieur aux autres
évidemment lorsqu'elle a parlé des
soignants des soignants avec qui on
avait empêché de travailler parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas vaccinés ça aussi elle
parle de liberté oui elle parle de
liberté et puis là elle s'adresserait
mais une partie de son électorat
il ya beaucoup de deux personnels du
corps des lys d'or médical au sens large
des infirmières des ambulanciers des
brancardiers
qui sont des professions intermédiaires
des employés et qui sans doute se
retrouve dans le discours de marine le
pen on va parler des sondages dans un
instant parce que vous êtes sondeurs je
rappelle qu'avec munichois d'opinionway
mais quand même ce message de fatima sur
youtube qui nous dit elle est maligne
elle n'a pas parlé de l'immigration ni
des musulmans elle cache son programme
une fois de plus on revient rituel a
besoin de rassurer et c'est vrai qu'elle
a très très peu parlé d'immigration
alors que c'était un thème presque
historique du front national et du
rassemblement national oui mais d'une
certaine manière elle n'a plus besoin de
faire c'est un c'est un acquis c'est
quelque chose qui définit histore
pendant le front le front national elle
et elle est très associé à cette
thématique et elle a besoin de la
dépasser elle en a tout de même un peu
parlé mais elle a surtout beaucoup parlé
de l'international d'ailleurs ça fait le
lien avec sa conférence de presse d'hier
ça c'est la volonté de s'élever au rang
de chef de l'état elle a parlé aussi
beaucoup du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
thématique principale de cette élection
et puis elle est allée sur les aspects
strictement démocratique
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne la
politique au niveau local
qui sont aussi des des éléments qui lui
permettent d'élargir son répertoire et
de ne pas se laisser enfermer sur ce que
les anglo-saxons appellent et les one
single if you can't fight c'est à dire
les candidats quand vous leur expliquez
moi ça alors ce sont les candidats qui
sont associés uniquement à une seule
thématique one single ychoux candidate
une seule thématique je pense eric
zemmour exactement d'une certaine
manière c'est un peu la difficulté en
tout cas la limite de la candidature
directement je voudrais qu'on rejoigne
qu'on rejoigne vincent rose rond sur
place je sais que c'est lui qui est
derrière la caméra qui filme et je
voudrais qu'il nous raconte qu'il est en
train de voir ce qui se passe et puis et
puis aussi ce qu'il a pu vivre ce qu'il
a entendu à quel moment la sallaz plus
réagi qu'est ce qui a fait bondir les
militants de marine le pen 20 cents
oui thibault alors à tort je suis en
direct je vous montre je suis d'ici on
va on va suivre marie le biker train de
sortir et loire a coulé ça en même temps
on a les militants qui sont en train qui
s'est offert un bain de foule le
forcément c'est cet usage et vous
parliez d'aider des sujets qui ont fait
le plus réagir y en a eu beaucoup mais a
particulièrement électrisé la foule on
va dire que c'est sur les 15000
soignants et intégrés avec leurs
salaires payés dus pour les moines dont
vous ignorez des suspendus et là la
foule a vraiment scandé le nom de marine
locale doit aussi à un moment où elle a
parlé public le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
rogie les jeunes à ce moment là aussi de
l'afflux le grimpeur mais s'est enflammé
et sinon c'est sûr les épouses et chez
les jeunes les classiques hors intérim
sur le social sur l'immigration sur ces
sujets là on l'a beaucoup entendu lui et
laval à marie lebel qui continue décide
de quitter le palais des quizz jours à
avignon avec toute sa sécurité je suis
un peu loin je sais pas si vous voyez
bien mais elle est en train de parcours
et l'allée centrale actuellement et
tapant un peu compliqué d'arrêter mon
couple à ses militants
est ce que vous pouvez très bien on voit
très bien marine le pen c'est d'ailleurs
assez étonnant en terme d'image souvent
on a des candidats qui y viennent qui
prenait un bain de foule ailleurs mais
en meeting elle traverse la salle quoi
c'est pas forcément une image qu'on a
l'habitude de voir il faut de plus
proche des gens marine le pen oui vous
avez raison c'est tres c'est une image
qu'on voit souvent en début de meeting
le candidat qui fend la foule là c'est
plus plus atypiques deux fois de voir
cela en fin de meeting vous vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure un discours très
court 45 minutes ce n'est pas un format
habituel ya sans doute là contraintes
médiatiques du jt de 20h qui est l'a
obligé à réduire son temps de parole et
est donc là il ya la volonté peut-être
de faire des images de montrer qu'elle
est entourée de montrer qu'elle est
soutenue par sa base militante ce
meeting donc le premier de cet
entre-deux tours avec marine le pen qui
s'est exprimée donc pendant 45 minutes
depuis avignon le prochain meeting c'est
emmanuel macron samedi 7 à marseille et
on va voir une vraie différence d'image
à marseille ce sera au soleil sur la
plage la mer derrière des images très
fortes importantes qui vont circuler
pendant plusieurs jours
marine le pen elle ne cherche pas ça est
ce que vous savez pourquoi ce que vous
avez une idée en tout cas est ce que ça
marche de montrer une forme de
simplicité ce que les français préfèrent
cette forme de simplicité oui c'est
alors je vais peut-être une question de
budget aussi un jeu je ne sais pas mais
ils sont où des problématiques
financières qui entre
en ligne de compte
j'ignore quelle est la qu elle ait la
préférence des français entre les
meetings de plein air qui produisent
aussi une une impression sur
sur sur ceux qui les regardent à la
télévision sur sur internet sur les
réseaux sociaux ou des meetings en salle
le meeting en salle c'est évidemment un
format beaucoup plus ou plus classique
c'est un avantage tout de même c'est de
bien on maîtrise beaucoup plus
le public on l'a bien vu comment ça eh
bien on l'a bien vu par exemple lors du
meeting d'eric zemmour ouais on l'a vu
aussi leenders qui et quand il ya eu dvd
fatiguant macron assassins c'est sa voix
là et puis on l'a vu aussi avec emmanuel
macron il ya quelques jours à strasbourg
où dans la foule peuvent se mêler des
personnes qui peuvent interpeller
l'orateur est donc casser le rythme de
du discours c'est toujours des éléments
qui sont un petit peu difficile à gérer
quand on est quand on est un orateur
dans une salle qu'on maîtrise peut-être
un petit peu mieux ce paramètre là
d'autres questions notamment sur
l'international parce que je voudrais
qu'on parle de ça et là elle a discuté
elle a donné une conférence de presse
hier de près d'une heure avec derrière
des questions ça a duré presque une
heure et demie hier où elle a déployé
marine le pen sa politique
internationale diplomatie française
selon son idée et encore une fois elle a
insisté là dessus et j'ai beaucoup de
questions là dessus on me dit notamment
sur youtube que marine le pen si elle
est au pouvoir poutine aura le champ
libre il ya vraiment ce rapprochement
est ce qu'elle peut payer cette idée là
elle essaye de casser cette image et ses
propos du passé à propos de l'annuaire
petit nom alors je la volonté initiale
était d'abord de se présidentialiser
le rôle d'un chef de l'état c'est de
s'occuper de l'international
c'est quasiment 30 40 % parfois la
moitié de ces journées de travail de de
discuter avec ses homologues
pour international de s'occuper de
l'europe la france en ce moment occupe
la présidence de l'union européenne donc
c'est une composante majeure du de la
fonction du rôle quotidien du chef de
l'état et quand on prétend à cette
fonction il faut donner des gages de ce
point de vue là et puis il ya évidemment
un effet de contexte on l'a bien vu avec
l'activisme du chef de l'état dans
dans la volonté de maintenir un lien
avec vladimir poutine la france a un
rôle à jouer sur la scène internationale
peut être encore plus dans la période
dans l'époque actuelle est donc ces deux
éléments quand on les met ensemble la
volonté de se présidentialiser
et puis
la place le rôle que doit jouer la
france sur la scène internationale
tout ça ça incite marine le pen a abordé
in extenso cette thématique deux jours
d'affilée ces images de vincent rosereau
notre envoyé spécial à avignon de marine
le pen après son discours d'un an dans
ce ne sont pas des images avant le
discours marine le pen qui prend un bain
de foule parmi ses militants après sa
déclaration de presque 45 minutes qu'est
ce que ça peut changer frédérick michaud
est ce que les variations de sondages
que vous faites sont significatives
entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle ou pas vraiment non pas
vraiment quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'élection présidentielle dans
l'entre-deux-tours généralement le
rapport de force n'évolue pas vraiment
de manière très marginale
toutes les intentions de vote qui sont
conduites après le premier tour et avant
le le second reste généralement très
stable il ya une seule exception c'est
2012 en 2012 vous vous souvenez
peut-être que la politique en tout cas
la campagne de nicolas sarkozy dans
l'entre-deux-tours était une campagne
très à droite qui visait à séduire
justement les électeurs de marine le pen
avait porté ses fruits et on avait un
resserrement en hd des courbes qui dans
la dernière semaine était était assez
important ça n'avait pas été suffisant
il n'y a jamais eu il n'y a jamais eu
dans l'histoire électorale
de la présidentielle attendue vous allez
me dire que vous prenez un pari qu'elle
est le sondage aujourd'hui je la joue et
je dis qu'il n'ya jamais eu de
retournement de tendance y ait jamais eu
de croisement de courbes ça ne veut pas
dire que ça ne veut pas ça ne peut pas
arriver que ça n'arrivera pas mais
jusqu'à présent 10 élection
présidentielle jamais un seul
heureusement de court même en 2017 ah
oui alors c'est sale avec l'espoir né je
voulais vous poser on parlait du débat
voilà du débat alors il ya eu deux
moments importants dans cet
entre-deux-tours en 2017 ya eu d'abord
voir le pool avec cette impression que
marine le pen attaquer et prenez une
forme davantage serait emmanuel macron à
ce moment là le débat du second tour
marine le pen a avoué le même s'être
complètement manqué et là aussi pas
d'inversion de tendance quelques petites
variations dès le début de cette
première semaine de 2010 est emmanuel
macron a perdu un ou deux points après
les choses se sont stabilisées le le
débat fait perdre quelques points à
marine le pen mais quand vous regardez
la courbe sur deux semaines elle est
quand même relativement plate en fait le
débat a eu moins une un impact sur le
rapport de force électoral que sur
l'image de marine le pen c'était un acte
lourd parce que ça a démontré une forme
d'incompétence incompétence à débattre
et incompétence en la maîtrise des
dossiers
doivent être maîtrisées quand on
l'attend à la plus haute fonction de la
république et c'est pour cela que marine
le pen depuis plusieurs semaines montre
qu'elle veut se re crédibiliser
quels sont vos sondages aujourd'hui
votre dernier sondage c'était ce matin
expliquez-moi quelles sont les tendances
où vont les voix de jean luc mélenchon a
l'impression que c'est ça qu'on veut
savoir que les français veulent savoir
parce que ça peut déterminer l'issue du
second tour alors le le rapport de force
reste depuis plusieurs jours stable donc
dans la lignée des élections
présidentielles antérieures 53% pour
emmanuel macron 47% pour marine le pen
beaucoup plus serré qu'à cinq ans
beaucoup plus serré qui a 5 ans et un
second tour compétitif 53 47 c'est
nicolas sarkozy ségolène royal en 2007
oui donc c'est vrai on est quasiment sûr
donc c'est un second tour à deuxième
jour de deux parties de plastique de
partis classiques de parti de
gouvernement alors pour répondre
maintenant votre question sur dites-moi
les les intentions les intentions des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon c'est
plus de 7 millions d'électeurs quand
même ces trésors de guerre la clé du
scrutin de second tour elle est là en
tout cas une des clés avec l'abstention
aujourd'hui 40 % n'ont pas encore décidé
n'expriment pas d'intention de vote 30
5% se reporteraient sur emmanuel macron
35 % et 25 % sur marine le pen donc on a
quand même un quart des électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon qui voteraient pour
marine le pen on voit bien que ça laisse
un goût différent tu m'as différence
majeure entre les deux il ya quasiment
repas ya dix points d'écart et un petit
peu plus petits sur vote pour pour
emmanuel macron mai
voilà marine le pen parvient à
séduire un quart de ses électeurs si je
regarde l'électorat de yannick jadot est
beaucoup plus resserrés évidemment alors
on imagine que cet électorat là va plus
vers emmanuel macron alors très
majoritairement 72% 13% vers marine le
pen et l'électorat de valérie pécresse
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que
parce que c'est la 4e quatrième
candidate dans cette élection 5e les
mêmes d'ailleurs exe mot pardon mais il
ya quand même un gamin socle à quelques
voix qui peuvent faire la différence
quand on est aussi serré qu est ce que
ça vaut 52% irait chez emmanuel macron
52 points il a appelé à titre personnel
directement l'a fait le premier soir
quelques minutes après la défaite 28%
chez marine le pen et 20% qui pour
l'instant n'expriment pas d'intention de
vote c'est-à-dire pourrait s'abstenir ou
pourraient voter blanc on se rappelle
qu'en 2017 les électeurs de françois
fillon du premier tour et les électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon avait beaucoup
plus voter blanc que les autres c'est en
partie cela qui avait assuré cette
explosion du vote blanc à laquelle nous
avions assisté en 2017 et puis pour
terminer les électeurs de d'eric zemmour
est alors 80 % d'entre eux se reportent
assez mécaniquement sur
ça c'est un vote quasiment quasiment
gagné pour pour marine le pen et demain
il faut que ça se traduise en va
retrouver tout de suite vincent rose
rond qui est sur place l'idée avec a il
est avec louis aliot et on va l'écouter
vincent vous avez la main pour poser
toutes vos questions aux mères du
rassemblement national de perpignan
oui je suis avec louis aliot
effectivement monsieur radio comment
avez vous trouvé le meeting de marine le
pen aujourd'hui par écouter le meeting
beaucoup d'âmes 12e un très bon discours
qui s'adresse à tous les français et qui
ouvre des perspectives de victoire c'est
sûr maintenant c'est à tous les français
qui ont écouté tout section dans lhassa
et porter la bonne parole parce qu'il
faut convaincre rassurer convaincre
rassurer la clé et dense est dans cet
état d'esprit c'est quoi le but
aujourd'hui c'est d'arriver à convaincre
les attentats lisent sur tous et c'est
ça votre but c'est de poser le discours
voilà il s'adresse à tous les français
il pose un certain nombre de jalons en
matière de politique sociale en matière
de politique économique
en matière de politique institutionnelle
européenne
voilà on nous attend sur ces sujets là
eh bien il faut aller maintenant
convaincre les français que nous sommes
les meilleurs pour le défendre est-ce
que marine le pen va peut-être plutôt
mettre la barre d'un côté ou de l'autre
selon qui elle veut réussir à convaincre
d'écouter il faut convaincre d'abord
ceux qui souffrent le plus dans notre
pays donc cela dans le premier tour ils
nous ont rejoints comme d'ailleurs les
vingt mille communes rurales qui ont mis
marine le pen en tête pour parler à la
ruralité voilà et de ce point de vue là
c'est j'allais dire la clé de cette
élection faut arrêter de faire peur aux
gens comme on le voit depuis trois jours
ça ne sert à rien vous parlez des idées
il n'y a pas de péril démocratique il
n'y a pas de péril tôt tarrit
totalitaire pardon le seul péril qu'il y
aurait demain c'est si monsieur macron
été réélu pour cinq ans sylvain qu'être
confiant pour le pour le second tour
pendant une semaine
j'ai fait du sport toute ma vie et
puisque au dernier coup de sifflet final
il faut se battre et bien se battra
jusqu'au bout très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur aliou voilà timos était de
louis aliot maire de perpignan qui était
présent alors que marine le pen continue
je vais aller heureuse vers là-bas je me
laissais continue en plateau et marine
le pen continue son bateau maintenant à
l'extérieur je vais y aller car si
vincent allez-y en finir avec ces images
de marine le pen qui continue après son
meeting a pas quitté la salle
immédiatement 10 jours pour convaincre
10 jours pour vaincre voilà comment est
là elle a terminé son son discours et
puis elle a beaucoup insisté sur le bloc
populaire le bloc élitaire parlé à
l'époque du bloc européiste d'emmanuel
macron socialiser et elle le bloc
souverainiste c'est un peu changé c'est
plus tout à fait l ol s'oppose à
emmanuel macron elle aussi elle a fait
en sorte que ce cette revanche puisse se
faire d'une manière un peu différente
oui vous avez raison en 2017 c'était
les patriotes versus les mondialistes
on voit bien maintenant la
mondialisation avec la crise covin
trouve en tout cas si ce n'est une fin
en tout cas une nouvelle étape va
s'ouvrir et donc effectivement la
reprise d'un clivage
disons qu'ils plus
propre au pays
vrai qu'on regarde je voulais pardon
regarder marimba band très particulière
cette image a quand même un jusqu'au
bout avec ses militants pression quelle
est la rentrée dans sa voiture peut-être
mais jusqu'au bout vous me disiez avant
qu'on commence ce direct et au début de
ce direct que ces meetings c'était avant
tout pour mobiliser ses militants peut
être encore plus que les français
oui et des images comme celles-là qui
sont des images de faire 20 qui sont des
images d' enthousiasme de de confiance
ce 6 mai à ce sont des images qui donne
beaucoup de force à la candidate alors
évidemment ce sont des militants donc
ils sont ils sont convaincus mais on a
bien vu que la salle était très faim
avait beaucoup de répondant
chanter plusieurs plusieurs fois marine
présidente on va gagner et c'est donc ça
c'est c'est quelque chose de positif est
en tout cas ça envoie une image de
mobilisation là ce qu'est ce qui est
recherché à travers ce type d'image
c'est un effet d'entraînement sur les
indécis et sur les personnes qui
hésitent encore à voter pour marine le
pen voit la marine le pen qui vient donc
de quitter cette salle d'avignon du parc
des expositions d'avignon sur ces images
de vin s'arrosent rang avec ses
militants eux aussi qu'ils vont qui vont
quitter avignon prochain rendez vous
donc pour marine le pen qui devrait
s'isoler quelques jours elle elle va
évidemment parcourir la france elle
aussi ce week end mais elle s'isole en
début de semaine prochaine pour préparer
le débat et puis elle sera à arras jeudi
soir je voudrais qu'on remonte quand
même cette image du président macron lui
il était ce matin au havre avec edouard
philippe il était vous le voyez ici il
serre la main de son ancien premier
ministre voilà pour cette image il a
déambulé toute la journée au havre où il
a beaucoup parlé d'écologie lui il sera
donc samedi pour son grand meeting en
plein air à marseille on suivra ça
évidemment aussi sur le sur le figaro là
et frédérick michaud merci de m'avoir
accompagné e mail votre votre livre le
sacre de l'opinion une histoire de la
présidentielle et des sondages c'est
très intéressant et vous nous dites que
les sondages si ça peut servir et c'est
utile 1 dans ce bouquin je remercie
aussi vincent rose rond qui était qui
était sur place qui nous a fait vivre
tous et tout cela avec ces images
jusqu'au bout à samedi vincent vous
serez à vous serez à marseille on fera
la même chose donc pour ce meeting du
président candidat et puis merci à
julien qu'une aile en régie qui m'a
accompagné qui m'a permis de vous
montrer tout ça ce soir l on se retrouve
bientôt sur le figaro live merci bonne
soirée